funeral services for George Floyd are
scheduled for next week in his hometown
of Houston and yesterday a massive crowd
and I mean massive estimated at 60,000
people marched in the city to pay
tribute to him among them were members
of Floyd's family and Janet shamlian is
in Houston this morning and she was at
that March yesterday Janet good morning
what was it like Tony good morning the
sheer size of the crowd that filled the
streets of downtown Houston on Tuesday
was unprecedented more than double what
organizers had expected so large it
could have almost filled the football
stadium here it was loud at times it was
angry but it was peaceful it's as if a
small city descended on the streets of
downtown Houston a melting pot of colors
and ages marching side-by-side the crowd
is great all multicultural different
ages
peaceful passionate together led by
members of George Floyd's family and
city officials this was a call to action
I'm here to support everyone who's out
here
I think there needs to be changed while
peaceful frustration poured out on signs
and enchants he was also with someone
call a teachable moment generations of
families here together we can bring our
kids out here necks for justice in a
peaceful way so that's why I felt safe
enough to bring them out here to protest
with us
organizers underestimated how many
people would show up saying maybe 20,000
it quickly soared well past that your
join us from Houston and more than a
dozen members of his family were here
overwhelmed by what they saw rappers
trade the truth and bun B were the
forces behind all this
the city was ready to come together they
said in the name of George Floyd the
body of George Floyd will comes home to
Houston this weekend ahead of a public
viewing on Monday and a funeral on
Tuesday a funeral reps for Floyd
Mayweather's say the former boxing champ
will pay all expenses for Tony got some
good news they're really amazing to see
such a large and peaceful crowd Janet
thank you very much